de fines feuilles d'or très fragile
comme matériaux de production
marlène voisin est artisan d'horreur
elle travaille sur un cadran siens après
l'avoir redimensionner elle peut
commencer à le doré donc on utilise le
sous le couteau et des petits pinceaux
vous avez la palette en poils de martre
et puis les petits pinceaux en petits
gris qui me servira à appuyer la feuille
d'or ça c'est que de l'eau c'est pour ça
qu'on appelle ça une dorure à la
détrempe parce que notre support lui
qu'on a appliqué est à base de colle
donc quand on vient l'humidifier sarah
vit de la colle c'est de la colle de
peau de lapin et du coup quand ça sèche
et ben ça tient arrivé en 2008 à
versailles pour ouvrir son atelier
l'artisan à la dorure dans la main
depuis son adolescence j'ai commencé
j'avais 15 ans quand je me suis mis à à
m'orienter là dedans donc c'est un
apprentissage qui dure sur trois ans axé
à peut-être de dorures plus dur cela
arrive à trouver un formateur en fait
quelqu'un qui veuille bien nous former
parce qu'on n'est pas nombreux
avec un chiffre d'affaires de 55 mille
euros marlène s'appuie sur des clients
connaisseurs autres facteurs faisant la
rareté de ce métier les prix élevés
mon client sont assis fidal puis c'est
des métiers bon on n'est pas nombreux
donc en fait c'est beaucoup de bouche à
oreille aussi après on travaille aussi
pour des
musée des hôtels particuliers des
professionnels aussi
donc dans l'ensemble je pense qu'on va
être 150 200 à peu près à tourner sur
plusieurs années pour obtenir une dorure
de qualité toutes les étapes sont
importantes cadres miroirs ou boiseries
marlène travail plusieurs objets datant
du 16e au 20e siècle
sa restauration la plus marquante une
table de gibier d'époque louis xiv
les gens viennent avec leurs cadres leur
glace donc repositionne de la feuille
d'or dedans c'est un métier qui n'a pas
changé l'eau à des techniques par
rapport au xviie xviiie siècle qu'on
utilise les mêmes techniques les mêmes
produits
tout est artisanal en fait pour ce cadre
sculptés en bois du xviiie siècle
l'artisan démontre sa polyvalence est
essentielle dans l'exercice de son
activité
on vient faire tout un travail de pour
sage et dort parures avec les petits
faire pour redonner toutes les nervures
de la sculpture
malgré sa rareté la dorure perdure à
travers les siècles et les techniques
avec notamment grâce à la transmission
du savoir faire